Although it's not a rule that universally
applies, the general consensus is that the
best superhero movie adaptations are faithful
to the comic books they're based on - and
that includes in terms of the character costumes.Characters
who look nothing like their comic book counterparts
tend to be the ones that are most often criticised;
Doctor Doom in the recent Fant4stic reboot,
the awful version of Deadpool in X-Men Origins:
Wolverine, and Galactus in Fantastic Four:
Rise of the Silver Surfer, for example.In
this video, we'll take a look at some of the
best examples of movie characters whose looks
were taken straight off the pages of their
source material.
Here are ten superhero movies that nailed
the costumes according to the comics.
Batman in Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice
Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice really
wasn't received very well in general, but
one of the aspects of the movie that was deemed
to be a success was Ben Affleck's Batman - and
one of the main reasons for that was undoubtedly
the character's look.Batfleck's costumes - both
his regular costume with the grey bodysuit
and black logo, cape and cowl, and the powered
armour he wore to face the Man of Steel - were
taken straight off the pages of The Dark Knight
Returns comic book miniseries.
Given that The Dark Knight Returns is generally
seen as one of the best Batman stories of
all time, it was a smart move on Warner Brothers'
part to take influence from it.
Superman in the Superman: The Movie
Christopher Reeve's Superman is still arguably
the most iconic movie superhero of all time.
Having first appeared in 1978's Superman:
The Movie, he went onto appear as the Man
of Steel on three more occasions - and he
always looked as if he was taken straight
out of the pages of DC Comics.Looking back,
what Reeve's Superman wore was defintely a
little bit cheesy - and the comic book version
of the Kryptonian hero has been updated to
something a little cooler since then - but
the blue suit with red cape and red trunks
on the outside was undoubtedly totally nailed
when compared to the classic comic book costume.
Supergirl in Supergirl
The Supergirl movie is proof that, just because
a costume is good, it doesn't necessarily
mean that the character wearing it - or the
movie they're in - is going to be good as
well.
Helen Slater portrayed the titular character
and she looked just like her comic book counterpart
- much like how her character's cousin did
in the Superman movie - but she was terrible!Her
costume was essentially the same as Superman's
on the top half, but with a skirt in place
of Superman's red trunks and blue leggings
on the bottom half - just like in the comics.
However, the movie was awful, her acting was
terrible and, quite frankly, she was just
irritating.
Deadpool in Deadpool
After the monstrosity that was the X-Men Origins:
Wolverine version of Deadpool, fans of the
character were eager to see a more faithful
adaptation on the big screen - and 2016 provided
them with that.Ryan Reynold took on the role
again, but this time it wasn't a horrible
Frankenstein's monster version of Deadpool
- it was actually the Merc with a Mouth down
to a T. Reynolds IS Deadpool - and the fact
that his costume was exactly like the classic
comic book version really helped matters.
The unmistakable red bodysuit with black trim
was totally on point and we can't wait to
see him in the sequel.
Iron Man in Iron Man
If there's one modern comic book movie character
who could rival Christopher Reeve's Superman
as the most iconic of all time, it's undoubtedly
Robert Downey Jr.'s Iron Man.
The flagship star of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe first appeared in 2008's Iron Man
and has gone on to appear in a further six
films (including cameos), with several more
to come.Part of his success as a character
is certainly down to his look.
Everything from the red and gold Iron Man
armour to the suits and goatee of the Tony
Stark character is lifted straight from the
pages of Marvel Comics - and it obviously
helps that Downey Jr. has totally made the
role his own as well.
Spider-Man in Captain America: Civil War
In fairness to Sony, every movie version of
Spider-Man's costume prior to his debut in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe was pretty damn
good - especially the black one in Spider-Man
3 - but none were more faithful to the comics
than the one worn by Tom Holland.Holland made
his debut as the character in Captain America:
Civil War, wearing a classic bright red and
blue number, complete with the small Spider-Man
emblem from the character's first appearance
on panel, as well as eyes that expand and
contract to express emotion.
It really is the best Spidey suit yet and
we can't wait to see what Marvel Studios are
going to do with it going forward.
Loki in Thor
The Marvel Cinematic Universe is actually
quite rich in comic-faithful costumes, but
we don't want to saturate this list with them,
so we'll just include a couple of heroes and
one villain - the villain, in this instance,
being Tom Hiddleston's Loki.Loki first appeared
in 2011's Thor movie and his battle armour
- the one with the antler-like horns on the
helmet - was beautifully adapted from the
classic comic book version's costume.
It looked awesome and everything about it
screamed "God of Mischief".
He went on to wear it again in 2012's The
Avengers and will no doubt don it in future
MCU instalments.
Hit-Girl in Kick-Ass
Most superhero outfits are very slick and
polished - which, in many cases, leaves you
wondering how the people wearing them even
made them - but the costumes in Kick-Ass were
more grounded and how you'd expect them to
be in the real world.
That obviously makes them easier to reproduce,
but it was still impressive how well the Kick-Ass
movies depicted them.That being said, the
most impressive costume in comparison to the
source material in the Kick-Ass movies was
undoubtely Hit-Girl's.
It's exactly as it was in the comic books,
emphasises her limited resources, and manages
to effortlessly convey her as both a little
girl and a deadly killer - which is quite
the achievement when you think about it.
Rorschach in Watchmen
2009's Watchmen was actually pretty superb
in terms of its costumes in general - every
character looked impressive and fairly strongly
resembled their comic book counterparts - but
none were quite as intricately faithful to
the source material as that of Rorschach.Granted,
a costume that consists of a brown trench-coat,
a matching fedora and an inkblot mask isn't
exactly difficult to replicate in live action,
but that shouldn't take away from the fact
that it was done so well in this movie - and
it certainly didn't stop Jackie Earle Haley
from looking bad-ass as hell in the role.
Hellboy in Hellboy
Like Rorschach's costume, Hellboy's is pretty
simple - it's essentially just a coat, a pair
of trousers and, sometimes, a T-shirt or vest
- but don't let that detract from the fact
that the Hellboy movies that starred Ron Perlman
got the character's look exactly as it is
in the source material.Then, when you factor
in the fact that Perlman also had to undergo
an intense make-up and prosthetic makeover
to get in to "costume" in the first place,
and Hellboy definitely deserves a place on
this list.
He looked awesome and every bit as cool as
the character does in his titular Dark Horse
comic books.
Thanks for watching our video about superhero
movies that nailed the costumes according
to the comics.
Did you enjoy this video?
Which other examples do you think should have
been included?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.